But just as I was
giving up hope,
on the horizon...
Thank God.
Honestly. Thank God.
(speaking foreign language)
HAZEN: There they are.
I got them.
It's the camel train.
(camel bellows)
(man shouting)
HAZEN: Yes!
HAZEN: So, this is
the camel train, look at how...
It's amazing.
Wow, I cannot believe
I found it.
This is...
HAZEN: ...spectacular!
What's your name?
HAZEN: Kara Elema. Kara Elema?
KARA ELEMA: Kara Elema.
HAZEN: He is the leader of
this whole community here,
and the leader of this caravan,
this big train of camels.
Water! Oh, my god.
Thank you.
(camel bellows)
Meeting up with these nomads
is a lifesaver.
(camel bellows)
But we've all still got
quite a journey ahead of us.
(camel bellows)
Look at this.
All of this that you see right
there, the twigs, the materials,
the baskets, this is
everything that they own.
This is the, this is
the moving truck right here.
(camel grumbling)
The Gabra go to
extraordinary lengths,
traveling for weeks at a time...
(camel bellowing)
...moving entire settlements
across the desert
in search of new grazing grounds
for their herds.
(bellowing)
They're moving to bigger,
better pastures.
But it's all about being hopeful
because it hasn't rained here
for so, so long.
So as spectacular
as this whole event is,
this is an event
out of desperation,
and yes, there are smiles,
because people, there is hope
that life will get better
once they get
to their destination.
(grumbling)